so I'm here on the Khan Academy exercise
for mapping shapes and I'm asked to map
the movable quadrilateral onto
quadrilateral ABCD using rigid
transformations so here in blue I have
the movable quadrilateral and I want to
I want to map it onto this quadrilateral
in gray and we have a series of tools
here rigid transformations of
translation rotation or reflection on
the Khan Academy tool and of course we
can undo it so the technique I am going
to use to do this is I'm gonna first use
translation to make one of the
corresponding points overlap with the
point that corresponds to so for example
it looks like this corresponds to point
C right over here and so I'm going to
translate and so notice once I click
that I can translate this around so I'm
going to translate right over here to
point C and now let's see to make these
two overlap I really can't do any more
translation I made one point overlap do
I rotate or do I reflect well if I I
bought it right over here it looks like
I am doing a rotation let me try to make
use a rotation to make this segment
right over here overlap with segment C D
so let me do a rotation now and so let's
see yep this is looking good there you
go we did the rotation and we are done
now let's do another example so here
what do we need to do alright so I'm
going to do the same technique this
seems to correspond to Point C so I'm
going to translate first so translate
first and then there's something
interesting going on right over here
because I've actually been able to
overlap Point C and a by shifting it by
translating it I should say and so it's
not clear if I were to rotate it then I
would loot then I would lose the fact
that a that the point that corresponds
to a is now sitting on top of a and the
point that corresponds to C is now
sitting on top of C it feels like a
reflection and it looks like a line that
would actually contain the points a and
C if we reflect over that line then
we'll be in good shape so let me see a
reflection
so let me move the line see ya whoops
and there that's not what I wanted to do
so let's see let me move my line so that
is I think a good line of reflection and
then let me actually try to reflect and
there you go I was able to reflect over
that line and my clue that I had to
reflect over the line that contained a
and C is that the points a and C and
their images after the transformation
we're all sitting on top of each other
so that was a good clue that on a
reflection if if they're both sitting on
the line of reflection that they
wouldn't move so to speak and there you
have it so this was a translation and
then a reflection